it's great to get to speak with you i
just watched the film last night i have
a lot of thoughts um i just wanted to
know starting off what was your
inspiration
for this story and i know you were born
in macedonia but what drew you to this
period of time and
uh the folklore around it um
oh i kind of just wanted to do something
that transports you to another time and
place um and especially uh to capture
this way of life that existed for
thousands of years not just in what is
now macedonia but just like across
that region and it's very connected to
you know agrarian lives all across the
world um and 19th century macedonia was
just my closest entry point um
i had to do the least amount of research
that sounds lazy um let me just do a lot
of research um
and then in terms of
um
i just looked into the rituals and
traditions um of that period that time
and place and and also they're not very
abstract to me i i grew up with
all of my um grandparents
were grew up in villages and still went
back quite a lot that was a lot of my
weekends grudgingly when i was growing
up so the kind of lives of uh
capturing a kind of um
you know i i got glimpses of it growing
up and i wanted to sort of document that
before it disappears entirely um
and yeah that's kind of where it came
from
yeah
so what did you do
how did you go about creating the sort
of like magical lore i guess is the word
for it when it comes to how the witches
exist
in the world because it's very
interesting in the movie
how she sort of like shapeshifts into
other beings how did you go about
that idea oh mainly my principle was to
just try and keep it as simple as as
possible i kind of was using the the
being a which aspect purely as an entry
point
into this kind of you know reality that
we're working the story exists within
but then after that i just uh to me
they're just people um everybody the
people who are riches in the film and
the people who aren't um they're humans
uh with feelings and thoughts and you
know needs and wants and i just went
from there and in terms of um
uh the rules of uh uh that that
shape-shifting aspect it sort it just
comes from
um not just um eastern european
tradition but everywhere in the world
when women were accused of witchcraft
they were at all accused of having taken
the shape of another person or another
or an animal
and i thought well okay what an amazing
perspective on life if you can do that
so that was kind of the only
surreal aspect or unreal aspect that
kind of
took on and then i absorbed it within
the story so you know in terms of how
you become one and so on i i built a
system around it uh so the story could
stand on something but beyond that uh
once we had it he was literally just
keeping it about as simple as possible
and sort of
um you know it it's about the the the
eyes of the witches not the claws
this film so
wherever the eyes took me is where i
went the story and speaking on the sort
of eyes i also think
uh the main character nevina has a
really unique way of speaking it's sort
of lyrical can you talk about how you
figured out how you wanted her to
communicate
um yeah so
i was obsessed even um
there's an element of this story i came
up with when i was um in first year
university for a short story for an
assignment um
and i was briefly obsessed with uh
so-called wild children kids who were
found
at age 17 having been raised completely
uh removed from humanity
um
and
what i found out is that if you're found
before the age of 13 the part of your
brain that is responsible for language
still
can uh it's still not fully formed so
you can learn language and not if you're
found after 13 then you die
you're never capable of actually
learning language
so i just
went based on that premise
um and i felt like what what
uh she would be
that was instinctively it wasn't like an
intellectual process i read from
instinct
um and so instinctively i felt like what
what would her voice sound like and just
sentences were coming to me what is now
part of the voiceover um
in
kind of broken macedonian
broken archaic macedonian i should say
the film isn't a specific dialect from
the 19th century it's also again
connected to
how my grandparents spoke
um
and
yeah
i was very finnicky about which words
she would know which was she wouldn't
know um how they would be shaped and
also
how much she could absorb of language
around her as well if she hasn't you
know
been part of a community and belonged
and then how that would shape your
consciousness and then it's also that
thing of like
you know
if you're traumatized as a child it
leaves imprints on you so i that's you
know i didn't want her to sort of
magically learn how to speak
once she's suddenly around people but
also
didn't want her to not be communicating
at all once you learn how to feel and
connect with others that that does
obviously affect
how you can communicate and interact so
again i'm kind of
intellectualizing something that was
genuinely like a very instinctive
process and it's even things like you
know i remember like
a shot listening for the next day and
looking at a section it's quite late in
the film
um around the time when she's talking
anyway i i wouldn't
use spoilers but um
yeah i i was in serbia my husband was
like in australia we were you know just
communicating via zoom for about four
months and i remember like i just sent
him a screenshot of the script which he
read years ago and he just saw and i
didn't say anything and you just saw the
voiceover he's like oh my god you're
talking about me like you know so it
comes from
which to me i'm like i never write
autobiographically i don't really care
about seeing myself on screen i'm
interested in other people more but
you know it's it's a very instinctive
process and then
any time i'm talking about it i'm trying
to kind of figure it out cerebrally but
even i don't know if i'm right when i
say these things it's purely instinct
but i feel like that's very much like
the way you work it feels like
everything is out of you
you are all these women you are the
character and like you know finding way
to belong finding your voice
it was very you were the connecting
tissue in the
and and it created a world for us
and i feel like you every day you
released just the kind of the things we
didn't know you kind of let them come
out so it was we were all kind of
searching and you kind of open those
doors that you kind of open in yourself
right
there was a connection and i think all
you guys also then built on that uh it
was an exchange of energy
you know the character is written is
like
half a shell compared to what became
when she became all of you guys and you
know obviously a lot of me is in her i
feel like i'm i do feel like i'm also
present in the film um in that sense but
i feel like we all are um
in that in that way and yeah
yeah i'm actually curious numi um what
drew you to working on this project
because
you are an actor in the project but
you're also an executive producer can
you talk about what what caught your eye
when you saw this
um it's very rare that you
you get to be a part of something that
is truly
a collaborative
ensemble piece that and and and the fact
that we're all kind of carrying the same
soul and the same
heartbeat just made it so unlike
everything i've seen before and it's
like non-speaking part for most of us
and it's we really had to go into a
place where you're just like you're very
primal it's almost like being a newborn
and doing things for the very first time
like how do you walk when you've been
never walked before how do you know how
do you connect with creatures around you
do you do you lick do you do you touch
do you listen like it was just like an
awakening and you had to like i felt
like i had to peel off lots of layers of
what i thought was
you know a behavior pattern and just go
back to like not knowing anything and i
feel like the way
um
goron picked and she's like brought all
these different faces together to become
one it just felt like so unique and so
brave and playful at the same time
um and uh
it's it's one of the most extraordinary
and different projects i've ever been in
yeah and i think i i really want to ask
you guys about working with sarah
klamosca who plays uh
never enough for i think like a good
chunk of the film and
how it was both working with her and for
you knew me how it was sort of imitating
her style of acting for that character i
mean it didn't feel like
it was i that's why i kind of went with
goron was like the carrier like he felt
like he was the connecting tissue
because we were not mimicking or like
not copying each other you kind of said
you it felt like you kind of gave us
clues you gave us
um you planted small seeds and all the
actors and then you kind of guided us to
become the same sort of but it's that
was also it just came so natural and you
know when i watched the film i was just
so blown away by her performance it's
like you know i cried and i was holding
my breath and it's and i forgot that it
was like
you know kind of after a while you just
forget forget that it's different actors
you know this just become one sort of um
and that's something you did goran i
don't really know what you did you
hypnotized us
um and also but also they did every
actor brought something else to the
character and we started completely out
of order um and a lot of the actors
didn't even get to meet each other which
was um sad on a social level like a
creative play was fine
but um
no it was um i think yeah there's an
energy that connects them and then
whoever brought something it wasn't that
they were imitating each other like
literally the film isn't is about
we often mistake becoming human as
behaviors and uh ticks on the surface
but it's really about what's inside um
it's not becoming human on the outside
it's becoming human on the inside and it
was sort of instinctively again the same
approach with the actors you describe
what's going on the feelings the
understandings of the world
um
i i sort of uh i spoke again about the
wild child phenomenon and how that that
shaped other people in the past and uh
used examples of that
um and then in terms of whatever actor
if they kind of picked up a you know
behavioral pattern i would tell the
others who are coming up later on about
it they were always all informed about
the full you know map of the character's
internal world but um
no there wasn't there was there
definitely never any talk of like oh she
does this like this you do this like
this um and also obviously the character
never known grows through every
iteration and it's important if it
becomes just the same thing
um it's not a very interesting channel
you know
watching five people trying to behave
like each other i don't think it was
very something i wanted i want to see so
it was kind of very important to me that
they all brought their own thing and
then obviously it was up to the rest of
us to sort of acclimatize everyone so it
just becomes one single clean through
line in terms of the character's
emotional
line
yeah i definitely think that you could
see her slow development from
just being you know in that very closed
off environment to joining this
community of people and i wanted to talk
to you about the way in which you
approach how
nebana
has this community of women around her
and that she finds in comfort in can you
talk about exploring that and you know
the different female role models in her
life
um
so in what specific way talk about it um
um well how did you
what was the method in which that you
were exploring it like from her mother
her you know biological mother to
uh anna maria's character
to the community of
women that she's in with the village can
you talk about how you thought about
developing that and how you wanted to go
about that with her character
development
yeah uh again instinctive process i kind
of grew up very much surrounded by women
and in terms of my most intense
emotional relationships with within my
life from a young age and i could
understand female patterns of behavior a
lot earlier and easier than i could male
ones
um so that's probably reflected in the
film and then also
once the premise was kind of
crystallized and her personality was
crystallized then i was just like okay
this is the world she lives in how you
know what what would come at her first
like in terms of how she interacts
with everyone around her what would be
the first influences and and how how
would uh they expand in what stages and
how does that affect her in what stages
um so you know it was natural in those
kinds of
patriarchal societies which no longer
exist luckily we've moved on so much as
the world now um so you know in a
patriarchal society it's obviously
natural that um
her first the first
main people should be exposed to would
be women and that would be her first
entry point into humanity um and
you know that's what shapes it and also
i'm usually much more interested in that
because in terms of um what i found
growing up like the world of feelings to
me existed around women and and trying
to understand
humans behavior um you know when when
when a group of women talk about
feelings it's gossip when a group of men
talk about feelings it's art like i
always thought that was a big [ __ ]
because i always felt um
you know these conversations to me were
like
what most like
you know instinctively excited me but
also this is what helped me understand
things
um and yeah i think that's reflected
through which what she goes through and
that and i i think the story guides me
through
the pl the things that i find most
you know that i'm most emotionally
connected to and those were the parts
that i felt like i wanted to those were
the parts of the story i wanted to live
in and learn from
it it's truly felt like you see the
world
kind of through
female eyes it was like that when we did
this and you know she's like you know a
woman is supposed to cry like when a man
comes in and how you're supposed to
behave around men and you're supposed to
you know um do not look at them but
still like this all this like you know
the behavior that so many women and
girls we just do you know and then when
you pointed it out and it became when i
saw the film and the full like the full
scale of this it was like
it was really um brutal in a way to see
we're all like taught this way and you
kind of and the simplicity of the story
kind of made it really pop and how we
all kind of sort of brainwashed to
behave a certain way
from a very early age
you know and and it just became so
so clear to me that you goron probably
see it from a very you're probably
closer to most women than women are
well i mean it sort of does confirm like
when i was you know meant to be a boy
growing up like the the things that i
connected to were not what boys were
supposed to connect to and you know i i
knew how to hide that very well in terms
of
um this does not represent me and how do
i connect with people around me but like
yeah i i
i i used to play with dolls because
that's what was interesting to me
because you know
adults at least you could create a human
being that had feelings guns were not
interesting to me but like
i would have to do that in private or so
on and so forth so it's just a sense of
um i i think the fact that i was so
removed from my gender growing up
just pointed out how constricted it all
is and i think if you do grow up away
from
human influences the constructions
become that much more glaring
the things that are strange to her that
are very commonplace to us if you really
stop to think about it they are very
strange
you know and they're really really
strange
yeah for sure and i i really like the
way that was done and it seemed so
obvious to her when she to us once we
see her sort of react to it and feel
like this is weird and this is
not what my instinct would tell me to do
i really like that aspect of the film so
yeah i really want to thank you two for
speaking with me and i hope people get
to see this film it really
was an eye-opener and it was i liked the
balance of the horror and the more
mundane slice of life moments in it it
was really it was really great
thank you thank you so much
you